and finally today speaking of serious
trouble how do you feel about going to
war in Mexico not war with Mexico folks
but Republicans
are warming up to the idea of using the
United States military to take on those
nasty drug cartels down in Mexico
let me read you this from Politico
in recent weeks Donald Trump has
discussed sending Special Forces and
using cyber warfare to Target cartel
leaders if he's re-elected president and
per Rolling Stone ask for quote battle
plans to strike Mexico
Representatives Dan Crenshaw and Mike
Waltz both Republicans introduced a bill
seeking authorization for the use of
military force to put us at war with the
cartels Senator Tom Carter Tom Cotton of
Arkansas said he is open to sending U.S
troops into Mexico to Target drug lords
even without that nation's permission
and lawmakers in both Chambers have
filed legislation to label some cartels
as foreign terrorist organizations a
move supported by GOP Presidential
aspirants
so labeling drug cartels
as uh uh terrorist organizations
basically gives the government a lot
more leeway to send in U.S troops
without of course having to go through
getting all that authorization from
Congress officially declaring war if we
can just slap a broad label on them
we can kind of kill whoever we want to
kill
and that is unfortunately the way that
our government is set up in a post-9 11
world
here's the thing
this really isn't about the drugs
it's not believe it or not it's not
about the drugs what this is about
is being able
to bomb a Sovereign Nation
to shoot whoever we want to shoot down
in Mexico by claiming
they're a drug Smuggler
now imagine if you will a caravan let's
call it a caravan of people approaching
our Southern border
and then folks on Fox News and
Republican politicians and candidates
tell us we know a lot of these people
are are smuggling drugs
suddenly
you're able to apply that terrorist
label
to these so-called Caravans
and you can send one missile
you send a drone down there to take them
out
that's what this is about
it's not about the drugs folks it is not
about the drugs
it is about getting that label so that
they can use the military force so that
they can attack migrants so that they
can attack Asylum Seekers all by
claiming nope they had drugs they were
smuggling drugs we'll never know
right I mean we'll never be able to
fully find out if they did or didn't
have drugs
and that's the plan that's what this is
about
this is about a show of force
on our Southern border not deep in
Mexico but on our Southern border giving
the United States the Republican Party
the ability to kill anybody that they
don't want in this country
that's all the time we have for today
but we've got a great bonus show coming
up for you I am fair and cousins from
ring of fire thank you so much for
watching today I'll see you again
tomorrow